for months joe biden blamed president
trump for any and all coven 19 deaths
but now
joe won't even answer a simple question
about his
plan to battle covet 19 watch
mr biden the covet task force said it's
safe for students
to be in class are you going to
encourage unions to cooperate more to
bring kids back to classroom
sir
joining us now with more is fox news
contributor and former white house press
secretary sarah sanders
along with former acting dni rick reneau
welcome to you both
thanks for having us thanks trey uh
sarah did did you ever wish you were the
press secretary for someone who got
uh so so many easy questions and then
got offended when he actually got a good
one
you know i i wish that i could say i'm
surprised that
joe biden one didn't take tough
questions or two that he didn't have
hard questions to even
answer it's absolutely absurd how
little the press holds joe biden
and all of his allies accountable they
didn't do it during the campaign so i'm
not surprised that they're not doing it
now
but at some point i do think that he's
going to have to step up and answer some
of the questions that are put in front
of him
look i took harder questions by
breakfast every morning than joe biden
has taken
the entire year and a half that he was
running for president
president trump took questions almost
daily from the press
and i think it's absurd that they don't
hold his feet to the fire
and don't push him harder to actually
answer any questions
and when he does their softballs and
they're usually scripted
and stuff even that maybe my
eight-year-old daughter could probably
handle answering
you know sir you you raise a broader
point ambassador grinnell i
i i think we need a societal referee we
we need an orbiter i get the question
all the time where can i go for the
facts where can i go for the truth
um the duplicity of the media
you were ambassador you ran dni
i mean did you notice any disparity
between the way you were covered or
johnny rackler was covered as opposed to
the way chairman adam schiff was covered
look we we talk a lot about
democracy and and how democracy is
undercut
through different actions which i think
is really healthy but
there's no other uh thing that you can
say
undercuts democracy than a press that is
not
unbiased and an entire press corps in
washington dc that cheerleads
and is partisan that's a really recipe
for disaster when you think about
how to hold government to account
how to challenge power
we call this out when we see it in other
countries when you don't have a press
corps
that plays fair that that immediately
goes
for uh one side and protects that one
side at all costs
i also think we have to get to the point
those of us on the outside of washington
dc
we have to be smarter about what we're
asking washington dc to do because in
many ways i think we're asking them to
reform themselves
including the washington d.c press court
they all live there they work there they
go to school there they go to church
there they know each other
their social circle is dependent upon
each other and so
those of us on the outside we continue
to say oh these reporters need to be
unbiased and and they need to uh push
and hold the government accountable i
actually think we're at the point where
they're never going to do that and so
why do we keep pushing them to do it i
think we've got to start doing
it on our own which is where social
media becomes such an important tool
is to be able to check government and
push
out uh the facts as we see it let's not
rely on the media anymore because the
media
failed us and we got to stop asking them
to do something that i just
fundamentally don't think they'll ever
do
sir we have about 30 seconds what what
what should a careful
observer be looking for in in the early
days of joe biden's administration to
see whether or not the media
is going to do its job and be that
neutral detached arbiter
well i think the most important thing
that people can look for and one of the
things
oh sorry go ahead rick no no no
go sarah i i was just saying that one of
the things i always say you can tell a
good
news story versus an opinion-based story
is whether or not
you can tell which side of the story the
journalist is on
if you can't that's a true news story if
there is a lot of
bias injected into the story and you can
tell that they lean to the left
that's not a news story that's an
opinion column we have gotten so much
into a gray area that we've got to go
back to having accountability in
journalism
that has been lost in society today and
we have to hold their feet to the fire
we need to make sure that there is
separation between what's news and
what's opinion
and the only way i think to tell that is
if you have no idea what side the writer
falls to
and they'll think you'll be hard-pressed
to find that in most today's news
stories
we'll be watching sarah sanders
ambassador rick rennell happy
thanksgiving to you both